Oprah Winfrey reacts to President Donald
Trump calling her out on Twitter I don't
like giving negativity power
[Music]
okay so we're going in here
Trump one year in Oprah's recent sixty
minutes check in with American voters
one year into Trump's presidency
seemingly did not sit well with the
commander-in-chief the president took to
social media after the episode aired to
call the iconic talk-show hosts very
insecure and dared her to run for office
Oprah initially did not respond to the
tweet and she made it clear she is not
interested in the Oval Office job now
will not yeah you can I stand by that
but on Thursdays Ellen DeGeneres Show
Oprah did share her initial reaction to
the president's tweet I just thought
what what I actually really did was I
went back and looked at the tape to see
if there was any place that that could
be true did I feel like like a slant it
was slanted or biased I went back and
looked at every tape I called the
producer because what actually happened
was Wendy when you do 60 minutes you sit
in a room with at least seven other
people who critique the piece before you
air it before you do the introduction to
it and then they give you the critiques
and they critique every word and is this
but you have a whole panel the people
looking at it whether it was fair and I
had actually the first time I saw it I
said there's something missing here from
the conversation when I'd asked the
question of do you think do you care
about what other people think about
America and they only used the
Democratic side and I said I remember
the guy Matt had said no we're the only
people that are worried about other
countries our thinking was so I said
yeah I think you should go back and put
that in because it makes it more
balanced so I was working very hard to
do the opposite of what yeah I was hate
tweeted about
[Music]